Before we start today’s video, we need to ask you
a question: Are you alone in the room? Seriously,
are you alone? You may think that the room around
you is empty, but how can you really know that,
right? Think of the technology out there being
developed by groups like DARPA, the CIA, or even
the SCP Foundation - Secret agents in cloaking
suits could be standing around you right now,
watching your every move, without you even
knowing. You could tell someone about this,
but if you did, they’d think you’re crazy,
and nobody believes crazy people, do they?
Sometimes people’s whole worlds just collapse.
One day they’re living happy, successful lives,
with families and friends who love and care
about them. Then the next day, they’re truly
convinced that the US government is tapping
not only their phone calls and their emails,
but their thoughts. Perhaps even putting dangerous
brainwaves directly into their mind. Or they start
to believe that those loving family members and
friends seek to do them harm. Maybe they start to
believe their food is poisoned, and stop eating,
causing them to waste away from malnutrition.
Most terrifying of all, maybe they start
to see things that nobody else could see.
Monsters that defy rationality and shake
the very soul. Terrible, terrible things…
These are all, sadly, relatively common
symptoms of someone suffering from a severe
case of Schizophrenia - A mental illness with a
wide range of detrimental effects to sufferers,
first and foremost giving them an incredibly
complicated relationship with reality.
There’s sadly a lot of misconceptions in the
media about people who suffer from illnesses
like Schizophrenia, painting them as unstable
individuals who present a danger to the people
around them. In reality, people with a condition
like this are three times more likely to be the
victim of a violent crime. And they’re also more
likely to be the victim of something else, too...
Like we said earlier, sometimes
people’s worlds just collapse,
and in severe cases, they
might simply drop off the map.
And nine times out of ten, the reason for
that is SCP-870: The Maybe There Monsters.
Take the experience of Katrina Wayne.
She was an office temp in Tallahassee,
Florida, with an undiagnosed case of
mild schizophrenia. For the most part,
she was able to operate just fine at her job,
getting her work done at a satisfactory level
while also maintaining a decent social life after
hours. It came as a shock to everyone when she
began screeching horrifically in the middle of the
office. She backed herself up against the wall,
picking up nearby objects and throwing
them into the aisles at some invisible foe.
And this isn’t a metaphor: There really
was an invisible foe moving towards her,
and only she could truly see it. Seeing the huge,
scaly body of a mature alligator from the Florida
Everglades moving towards you would be scary
enough on its own, but this wasn’t any ordinary
alligator. Its long, reptilian head had three eyes
instead of two, and it moved towards her on eight
huge, articulated spider legs. It was like
something straight out of a nightmare.
Katrina was put on leave due to a stress-induced
mental breakdown and prescribed a course of
antipsychotic medication by a psychiatrist.
She disappeared from her home without
a trace a mere two weeks later.
Or take the story of Daryl Simon. He was a
mechanic working in Michigan with a family
history of schizophrenia, though he’d never been
officially diagnosed himself. He was working on
the engine of a vintage corvette when something
strange happened: His garage began to fill up with
smoke. He considered at first that perhaps it was
some kind of engine malfunction causing smoke to
belch out of the old corvette’s tailpipe, but then
he saw something standing in the smoke - A human
figure. Daryl suddenly felt a profound
sense of dread seeping into his mind.
He grabbed a monkey wrench and began to slowly
approach the intruder standing in the smoke.
It was only when he was already too close
that he realized that the figure wasn’t
just standing in the smoke. It was made
of smoke. The second he noticed this,
the figure’s eyes opened, glowing red. Its smoky
face opened into a wide, toothy mouth and let out
an ear splitting shriek. Daryl suddenly found
himself running as the creature gave chase. He
threw his wrench at it as he ran; it breezed
through the creature’s semi-intangible form.
Daryl was found later that day, huddled in the
corner of his garage, muttering incoherently.
After seeing a mental health professional and
sharing his story, he was given a schizophrenia
diagnosis. He was given a mix of talk therapy and
medication, and seemed to be improving over time.
He would occasionally report hallucinations
of the man made of smoke, watching from the
corner of his eye, but it was dismissed as
nothing more than that: A hallucination.
A month later, he was gone.
Never to be seen again. But he wasn’t the
only one to fall victim to the anomaly.
Shirley Nicholson, a retiree whose
schizophrenic symptoms developed later in life,
was having a quiet evening in her home when
she first encountered an instance of SCP-870.
She was watching a game show on television when
she heard a strange noise coming from her kitchen.
A rustling, like someone was messing
with the food inside her fridge.
Of course, she’d always had a tendency to hear
things, which was why she wasn’t that nervous
when she got up and walked into the kitchen.
That sense of confidence didn’t last long.
When she entered her kitchen, she saw the
fridge door open, with the back half of what
looked like a giant ant emerging from it. Her
breath caught in her throat. That giant ant,
which seemed to be eating the food inside her
fridge, suddenly froze, seeming to realize that
Shirley had entered the room. When it backed out
of the fridge, Shirley couldn’t help but scream.
Instead of antennas and mandibles, the
giant ant had a grinning, human face.
As Shirley screamed, the giant ant’s human
face began to cackle with sadistic glee.
Its jaw began to stretch open, impossibly
wide, exposing the never-ending darkness
within. Shirley turned and ran as the creature
skittered towards her at a frightening speed.
Adrenaline kicked in, and Shirley ran for her
life as the monster pursued her through the house.
It was only when she ran out into the
street, and was seen by others in this
bizarre outburst, that the horrifying
ant monster seemed to disappear.
And several weeks after her
schizophrenia diagnosis,
Shirley Nicholson sadly disappeared too. Before
she vanished, she made a panicked 911 call,
where she screamed down the line
that the monster had come back.
No explanation has yet to be found, but there
are more cases to be investigated still.
Don Jones, who had a documented history with
schizophrenia, had his SCP-870 experience while
waiting for the bus out of town late one October
evening. He was checking his phone at the bus stop
when he saw a figure shuffling towards him in the
distance. He tried to ignore it at first - Years
of therapy had taught him to try his best
to ignore these strange little anomalies.
He’d been medicated for years, and while
occasionally he had minor episodes,
he’d lived with the condition for long
enough now that he’d learned how to cope.
That’s when the strange,
shuffling figure got closer.
Don looked up, just for a moment, to see the
thing coming towards him out of the dark. It was
about the size of a child, though a little shorter
because of how far the creature was hunched over.
Literally, hunched, the entity had a rather
prominent hunchback. But this wasn’t nearly
as noticeable as the thing’s face: It had the
head of a particularly mangy-looking parrot,
its curved beak caked in
what looked like old blood.
This was stranger than some of the
hallucinations he’d suffered in the past.
It looked more tangible, more real, even
after years of medication and therapy.
He felt nervous as the thing approached
him. On some subconscious level,
he knew the thing intended to
harm him in one way or another.
When it opened its mouth, and sunk the
bladed tip of its beak into Don’s hand,
he knew that he wasn’t dealing with any
mundane fantasy here. He screamed and ran
off into the night, the monster giving chase.
He later reported the incident to the police,
but his fears were written off when
his medical history came to light.
Everyone just assumed the man was experiencing
another episode, and that the wound in his
hand was self-inflicted. Of course, as
you’ve probably gathered by this point,
poor Don Jones would disappear
without a trace not long after.
Still, the testimonies get freakier...
A warehouse security guard, Alex Landry, had
his terrifying encounter while on the job.
He was on his nightly patrol when he heard a
strangely soft skittering noise coming from
inside the warehouse. He deployed his flashlight
and ran inside after radioing for assistance.
He was expecting maybe an escaped
animal or a young hoodlum messing
around inside. What he didn’t expect was
a face-to-face encounter with pure terror.
As his flashlight’s beam traced its
way up to the top of the warehouse,
he saw a monster crawling across the ceiling.
It was a giant, fifteen-foot-long centipede,
but instead of having normal centipede legs,
it had scores of twitching, grasping human
arms. He was found in a comatose state
by his partner, and spent the brief rest
of his life in a psychiatric facility before -
you guessed it - disappearing without a trace.
And most exhilaratingly, we
come to the tale of Mr. Holgate,
which both ends a little more hopeful for him, but
paints a grim picture of what happened to everyone
else. Mr. Holgate had encountered a spider-like
creature with a freakish number of legs,
which he soon realized only he could
see. During his periods of observation,
he’d seen the creature both devour a
ruler - as in, the measurement device,
not a king - as well as swallow a human whole
after an extended period of stalking the victim,
leaving nothing behind. Just like the SCP-870
instances had done to all their other victims.
When the monster eventually came
for Holgate, he was ready. It ran
screeching towards him on its too many legs,
and Holgate whipped out a gun and shot it.
The Foundation has prioritized the
capture or destruction of SCP-870.
It’s believed to be not a single
instance, but an entire species,
living out there, preying on humans and hiding
in the space between our perceptions. Even two
schizophrenic people looking at the same instance
will report seeing completely different entities.
The monsters are all the more dangerous due to
the fact that sufferers of severe schizophrenia
often report hallucinations of strange monsters
or entities, so their pleas for help are often
ignored by neurotypical authorities. Neurotypical
meaning those who don’t experience any form of
mental illness, personality disorder,
or developmental condition - People
who could never see SCP-870 coming until
they’re already being swallowed whole.
The lead researcher on the SCP-870 case follows up
the file on the monsters with an ominous note that
leaves little comfort for even those of us who
don’t suffer from schizophrenia. The note reads:
“I, personally, don't believe that the
schizophrenics are really seeing SCP-870 fully,
they can just see it more than us. We don't see
it because our brains aren't made to see it.
The schizophrenics, their brains are
wired up just that tiny bit differently,
and they can see it just a tiny bit more. These
things have the perfect camouflage, and
we simply are unable to see through it.”
To return to what we said at the
very beginning of this video.
Look around the room and answer
our question: Are you alone? Now,
at least you know the answer to that
question may not be as simple as it seems...
Now go check out “Evil Monster
Created by SCP Foundation
SCP-2419 - The Laughing Men” and “Revenge of
D Class Ghosts SCP-4973 - Dead Men Walking”
for more scary anomalous beings that’ll
have you looking over your shoulder!